state with the largest economy will
reopen this morning
california was one of the first states
to shut down more than a year ago
and is one of the last states to lift
those restrictions
carter evans is at dodger stadium in los
angeles carter
how's life going to change today
oh a lot is going to change good morning
adriana throughout the past year the
home of the dodgers here
it served as both the covent testing
site and a vaccination center well
tonight
the stadium opens to full capacity
that's 56 000
fans for the first time since the
pandemic began
now from amusement parks to bars and
restaurants capacity limits and social
distancing requirements
are lifted as of today and people who
are fully vaccinated they can ditch
their masks in most situations like jams
and grocery stores
unless a business wants its customers to
keep wearing them
now if you're not vaccinated it's still
recommended that you wear a mask in
indoor settings and
everyone vaccinated or not is going to
have to continue wearing face
coverings in places like hospital
schools and on public transportation
now california's governor says the state
has now administered now
more than 40 million coveted vaccines
that's the most of any state here in
dodger stadium tonight
they're going to be offering vaccines to
ticket holders through
the 7th inning tony all right on behalf
of my wife carter i'll have to say
go dodgers thank you very much